Transcription: Edith Félicité Koumtoudji
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour.
Alors, les conférences TED sont
bien souvent l'occasion d'entendre
de très beaux messages d'espoir.
En ce qui me concerne,
je viens tenter plutôt
aujourd'hui
de vous désespérer.
Je ne veux pas vous
désespérer totalement.
J'imagine qu'un désespoir total
conduit au suicide,
ce que je ne souhaite évidemment
à personne ici.
Je veux plus précisément tenter
de vous enlever un espoir,
l'espoir que notre civilisation
puisse durer encore longtemps,
un espoir qui s'exprime
par exemple,
dans cette notion omniprésente
de développement durable,
ou dans celle plus récente
de croissance verte.
Pourquoi vouloir vous ôter cet espoir,
à vous qui êtes si jeunes,
pleins d'enthousiasme,
de belles idéees,
d'énergie positive ?
Parce que c'est, je crois,
l'une des conditions
pour éviter peut-être,
je dis bien peut-être,
une terrible catastrophe.
Je m'explique :
depuis plus de 50 ans
maintenant,
des travaux de recherche
s'accumulent
pour souligner une contradiction
fondamentale
de notre civilisation.
Nous vivons dans un monde fini,
aux ressources limitées,
et pourtant,
nous visons une croissance
économique infinie,
une croissance illimitée.
Certes, l'univers est immense,
peut-être même infini,
mais pour le moment au moins,
l'espèce humaine n'a pas d'autre endroit
que la planète Terre où se reproduire.
Nous habitons donc bel et bien
un espace fini,
un espace dans lequel même nos
ressources dites renouvelables,
ne le sont que jusqu'à un certain point.
Une espèce vivante trop malmenée
finit par disparaître.
Pourtant,
nous prétendons pouvoir produire
dans cet espace relativement clos
toujours plus de biens et de services,
en un mot, toujours plus de marchandises.
Dans la mesure où cette production
implique nécessairement
la consommation de
ressources terrestres
et la production de déchets,
elle ne peut pas croître indéfiniment.
Pour avoir une croissance économique
durable ou soutenable,
il faudrait que son impact écologique
se stabilise, voire décline,
ce qui n'est point ce que nous
observons actuellement,
malgré des discours rassurants
sur les effets bénéfiques
d'une dématérialisation progressive
de nos économies.
Il y a plusieurs raisons à cela.
Tout d'abord,
l'économie de service n'a pas remplacé
l'économie industrielle,
elle s'est ajoutée aux activités
industrielles qui,
pour une grande part
ont été délocalisées.
À l'échelle planétaire,
l'impact écologique de nos économies
s'est donc accru.
Par ailleurs, l'économie dite du savoir
ou de l'information
n'est pas si immatérielle qu'on veut bien
le croire ou le dire.
Sur le plan énergétique
en particulier,
nos petites machines informatiques
et des infrastructures
qui permettent leur usage
sont très gourmandes.
Un iPhone consomme en moyenne
autant d'électricité
qu'un réfrigérateur standard.
Plus simplement encore,
des marchandises immatérielles,
cela n'existe pas.
Même pour vendre un service,
il faut au minimum un humain
qu'il convient de nourrir, d'habiller,
de loger, de transporter, etc.
On peut donc très difficilement
vouloir produire toujours
plus de marchandises
sans accroître toujours plus
notre impact écologique.
Bien sûr,
nous pouvons
réaliser certains progrès
dans l'utilisation
des ressources terrestres,
mais ces progrès sont limités,
notamment par un phénomène :
l'effet rebond.
Il a été repéré il y a plus d'un siècle
par l'économiste Stanley Jevons
qui avait remarqué
que les gains d'efficacité
des machines à vapeur
ne se traduisaient pas
par une baisse
de la consommation du charbon
mais par une hausse
de cette consommation.
Pour quelles raisons ?
Mais parce que le charbon
devenait ainsi
toujours plus rentable à utiliser.
Dans une société productiviste,
tout moyen d'économiser une ressource,
va, en fait, souvent,
en stimuler la consommation.
On peut aussi bien sûr
mettre en place des incitations
pour réduire cette consommation
ou réduire la production de déchets
suivant le principe
de l'utilisateur payeur
ou du pollueur payeur.
Mais ces dispositifs,
s'ils ne sont pas
simplement symboliques,
vont en fait imposer généralement,
un ralentissement
de ces activités économiques.
Ils ont donc toutes les chances
de faire l'objet de vives oppositions
comme l'a montré par exemple,
la révolte des Bonnets rouges
contre l'éco-taxe
en France à l'automne dernier.
Dans des sociétés qui dépendent de la
croissance économique,
toute mesure qui menace
de ralentir celle-ci
risque d'être rejetée
par la majorité.
On en vient donc à cette
contradiction fondamentale :
il y a des limites physiques
et biologiques
à notre capacité à produire
toujours plus de marchandises,
mais en même temps,
nos sociétés reposent sur
la quête de croissance
et nous agissons donc
comme si ces limites n'existaient pas.
Dans ces conditions,
le moment va arriver
fatalement où,
soit par manque de ressources
soit par trop plein de déchets,
ces formidables machines à produire
des marchandises
que sont les entreprises,
ne vont plus pouvoir tourner.
Nos économies vont alors
s'effondrer
et une grande partie des 7, 8, 9,
ou 10 milliards d'humains
qui peupleront la planète
vont tout simplement disparaître.
Pour le dire de manière imagée,
lorsque le garde-manger se vide
et que la poubelle envahit la cuisine,
il faut s'attendre à ce que
le gâteau que l'on y prépare,
ne puisse plus nourrir toute la maisonnée,
mais qu'en plus, il empoisonne
ceux qui le mangent.
Quand est-ce que cet effondrement
de nos économies
risque-t-il de se produire ?
Sans doute bien plus vite
qu'on ne le pense.
La croissance économique en effet,
même à un taux peu élevé,
suit une progression exponentielle,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle accélère constamment.
Pour illustrer
cet effet d'accélération,
on peut évoquer
l'exemple classique du nénuphar
dont la surface double chaque jour
et à qui il faut 30 jours
pour recouvrir l'étang
sur lequel il pousse.
Au début, sa progression est lente,
à peine perceptible
d'une journée à l'autre.
Le 28e jour,
encore seul 1/4 de l'étang
est recouvert de nénuphars,
Mais le 30e jour, c'est terminé.
Deux jours ont suffi pour
que les 3/4 de l'étang soient envahis.
La croissance de nos économies
ne double pas chaque année ;
elle n'en reste pas moins exponentielle.
À 2% par an, le volume
des marchandises produites,
va doubler non pas en 50 ans,
mais en 35 ans.
Du coup, son impact écologique
tend également à suivre
une telle progression.
On est aux prises ici avec
les phénomènes de rétroaction positive.
Les spécialistes des systèmes
désignent ainsi
les effets d'un processus
qui ont tendance à renforcer ce dernier.
Autrement dit, la conséquence d'un
phénomène
devient elle-même
l'une des causes de celui-ci.
Un bel exemple,
si j'ose dire,
est celui de certains effets
du réchauffement climatique.
Ce réchauffement fait fondre actuellement
les neiges et les glaces qui réfléchissent
les rayons de soleil
et contribuent de la sorte,
au refroidissement terrestre.
La disparition de ces neiges
et de ces glaces
va donc encore augmenter le
réchauffement de l'atmosphère.
Autre rétroaction positive du même genre,
la fonte du pergélisol,
qui retient prisonnier
d'énormes quantités de méthane,
un gaz à effet de serre,
dont la libération dans l'atmosphère
devrait aggraver rapidement
le phénomène du réchauffement global.
En somme,
notre situation sur le plan écologique
risque de se dégrader,
sinon d'un seul coup,
en tout cas d'une manière soudaine,
ne nous laissant plus guère de temps
alors pour réagir.
En outre, certains dégâts
seront devenus irréversibles.
On ne recréera pas,
d'un coup de baguette magique,
les espèces animales
qui sont en voie d'extinction aujourd'hui.
Cette thèse de l'effondrement
est de plus en plus admise
par ceux qui tentent d'appréhender
ces questions
dans leur globalité.
Elle n'est pas nouvelle.
Cependant, cela fait plus de 40 ans
qu'elle est défendue, entre autres,
par l'équipe de Dennis Meadows.
Cette équipe de chercheurs
travaillant au MIT à l'origine,
a tenté, au début des années 70,
de modéliser
les interactions entre l'espèce humaine
et la planète Terre,
en se servant de la théorie
des systèmes et de l'informatique.
Leur objectif n'était pas tant
de prédire l'avenir
que de comprendre la dynamique
du système global
Les différents scénarios générés
par leur modèle
aboutissent tous à la même conclusion :
sauf si nous stoppons la croissance
économique à l'échelle mondiale,
notre civilisation
se condamne à l'effondrement,
et cela probablement
avant la fin du 21e siècle,
car nous sommes d'ores et déjà,
en situation de dépassement
des limites écologiques de notre planète.
Dans le cas du scénario standard,
celui dans lequel rien n'est fait
pour corriger les problèmes causés
par la croissance économique,
l'effondrement débute même
avant 2050.
Or, si l'on observe
ce qu'il s'est réellement passé
depuis que ce scénario a été élaboré,
on constate que sur le plan économique,
démographique et écologique,
les choses se sont déroulées
d'une manière très semblable
aux projections de ce scénario
qui était aussi baptisé
« business as usual ».
C'est d'autant plus préoccupant
que les efforts qu'il faudrait accomplir
pour tenter de stabiliser la situation,
sont désormais bien plus considérables
qu'au début des années 70.
Nous avons perdu un temps précieux
qu'il sera difficile de rattraper.
Pour l'équipe Meadows qui a actualisé
récemment son étude initiale,
nous avons toutefois encore le choix,
un choix très restreint cependant,
entre, d'un côté,
une décroissance forcée, subie,
qui s'imposera spontanément
et de manière catastrophique
d'ici quelques décennies à peine,
et d'un autre côté, une décroissance
volontaire assumée,
contrôlée autant que possible
et lancée sans plus attendre.
Cette deuxième option,
celle d'une décroissance choisie,
repose sur l'espoir
d'une sortie en douceur
de notre modèle de civilisation,
une sortie pas trop désastreuse
pour l'espèce humaine.
Bien sûr, à cet espoir,
on peut opposer celui d'une série
d'innovations technologiques majeures
qui résoudraient le problème
de la fin du pétrole
ou celui des gaz à effet de serre
par exemple
et permettraient ainsi,
de poursuivre la croissance
en éloignant le risque d'effondrement.
Une telle éventualité
est très peu probable
mais pas impossible.
Est-ce raisonnable de faire le pari
qu'elle advienne ?
Je ne le crois pas.
Toutefois, l'avenir reste inconnaissable
et on ne peut empêcher personne
de se raccrocher à un tel espoir,
aussi peu fondé soit-il.
Cela dit,
il y a d'autres bonnes raisons
de vouloir en finir avec la course
à la production de marchandises
dans laquelle nous sommes embarqués
à l'échelle planétaire.
Et c'est celle que je voudrais évoquer
à présent
dans la 2e partie de mon exposé.
Tout d'abord,
il faut prendre conscience
que cette fameuse croissance
ne constitue plus un facteur de bien-être
dans les sociétés les plus riches.
Elle semble l'être encore
dans les sociétés les plus pauvres,
mais plus dans les nôtres.
Au-delà d'un certain niveau
de PIB par habitant,
la corrélation disparaît, en effet,
entre croissance économique et bien-être,
que celui-ci soit appréhendé
à partir d'indicateurs subjectifs
comme le sentiment de bonheur
ou d'indicateurs objectifs
tels que le niveau de scolarisation
ou encore l'espérance de vie.
Dans le cas du sentiment
de bien-être au quotidien,
il n'y a plus de corrélation
avec le PIB
dans les pays où celui-ci dépasse
environ 15 000 $ annuels par habitant.
Dans le cas du niveau d'éducation,
ce seuil se situe autour de 12 000 $
annuels par habitant.
Dans le cas de l'espérance de vie,
ce seuil est environ à 18 000 $.
Pour mémoire au Québec,
nous sommes bien au-delà de ces seuils
puisque le PIB par habitant
y dépasse les 30 000 $ annuels.
Si l'on ajoute à cette décorrélation
entre PIB et bien-être,
le fait que la croissance économique
ne génère plus forcément d'emplois
dans nos sociétés,
à quoi bon poursuivre cette course
à la production de marchandises ?
Pourquoi en faire un impératif absolu
comme le font nos dirigeants politiques
et économiques ?
À qui profite vraiment
cette croissance,
sinon à une toute petite frange
de la population de nos pays ?
Si l'on souhaite véritablement augmenter
le bien-être du plus grand nombre,
il semble
qu'une solution prometteuse
se trouve du côté
d'une réduction des inégalités
au sein de nos sociétés.
Sur ce point,
je vous renvoie en particulier
aux travaux de Richard Wilkinson
et au livre qu'il a publié
avec Kate Pickett sur le sujet.
Wilkinson a offert également
au moins une conférence TED.
Vous y apprendrez, entre autres choses
intéressantes,
qu'en matière d'espérance de vie,
mieux vaut, par exemple, être
un pauvre Suédois
qu'un riche Anglais.
L'égalité des conditions
profite à tout le monde,
alors que l'inégalité
affecte même le bien-être
des mieux nantis.
Telle est la thèse centrale de Wilkinson
qui vaut vraiment la peine de découvrir.
Une chose est certaine,
la croissance économique
a cessé d'être un facteur de mieux-être
pour les humains actuels,
au moins en Occident.
Si l'on considère en outre
que la poursuite de cette croissance
menace l'avenir de l'humanité,
on dispose donc à présent
de deux bonnes raisons de refuser
cette course à la production
de marchandises.
Mais on peut aller plus loin.
Cesser de courir collectivement après
l'augmentation de notre PIB
pourrait également s'avérer libérateur
pour la plupart d'entre nous.
Cette course est très dure en effet,
y compris pour ceux qui
en occupent la tête.
Elle repose sur
une concurrence généralisée
entre nous tous,
le « nous » désignant à présent
l'humanité entière, ou presque.
Le sociologue Max Weber en parlait
comme d'une cage d'acier
qu'il décrivait ainsi :
« Chacun trouve aujourd'hui, en naissant,
l'économie capitaliste établie
comme un immense cosmos,
un habitacle dans lequel il doit vivre
et auquel il ne peut rien changer,
du moins en tant qu'individu.
Dans la mesure où l'individu est impliqué
dans les rapports de l'économie de marché,
il est contraint à se conformer
aux règles d'action capitalistes.
Le fabricant qui agirait continuellement
à l'encontre de ces règles,
serait éliminé de la scène économique,
tout aussi infailliblement
que serait jeté à la rue
l'ouvrier qui ne pourrait
ou ne voudrait s'y adapter. »
Autrement dit,
chacun doit trouver le moyen
de contribuer
directement ou indirectement
à la production de marchandises,
sous peine de rester
sur le bord du chemin.
Quiconque n'y parvient pas,
non seulement perd toute autonomie
sur le plan matériel,
mais se retrouve également sans identité,
sans identité positive en tout cas,
d'où l'angoisse et le désespoir
de ceux qui sont sans emploi,
d'où aussi la peur, le stress, l'anxiété
qu'éprouvent
ceux qui ont la chance d'en avoir un
et qui craignent de le perdre,
d'où le surinvestissement
dans le travail
pour garder sa place
ou essayer d'en gagner quelques-unes,
d'où la surconsommation
de toutes sortes de substances,
reconnues ou non par le corps médical,
pour tenter de tenir le coup,
d'où les épidémies
d'épuisement professionnel,
les dépressions, qui frappent
un grand nombre d'entre nous.
Mais cette course
n'est pas seulement épuisante ;
elle a aussi quelque chose
de profondément insensé,
y compris sur le plan individuel.
L'écrivain Bukowski
exprime avec sa rage coutumière,
au moins une partie du problème :
« Comment diable un être humain
peut-il se réjouir,
de se faire réveiller à 6 h 30 du matin
par une alarme,
sauter du lit, s'habiller,
se forcer à avaler quelque chose,
chier, pisser, se brosser les dents
et les cheveux,
puis affronter des embouteillages
pour aller faire gagner
un paquet de fric à quelqu'un,
qui s'attend en plus,
ce qu'on lui en soit reconnaissant ? »
Nous n'en sommes pas tous là, certes,
il reste que nous avons appris
à trouver normal
de soumettre nos aspirations
les plus profondes
aux règles d'action capitalistes,
comme dit Max Weber.
C'est ainsi que bon nombre
des plus grandes décisions de nos vies
sont prises en considérant d'abord
la question :
« Combien cela va-t-il me rapporter
ou me coûter ? »
plutôt que la question :
« Ce choix va-t-il me permettre
de me réaliser pleinement,
de m'accomplir et de m'épanouir
en tant qu'être humain ? »
Pour en avoir souvent parlé avec eux,
je sais que beaucoup d'étudiants
de cette école
ont choisi de s'y inscrire,
non pas par goût pour la gestion,
mais, avant tout,
dans l'espoir de s'assurer
une place pas trop inconfortable
dans cette course
à la production de marchandises.
Ce faisant,
ils ont renoncé à des projets plus personnels ;
ils ont renoncé en somme,
à être eux-mêmes.
Ce n'est pas les critiquer
que de le souligner,
cette contrainte s'impose à tout le monde,
y compris à ceux qui, comme vous et moi,
disposent d'une marge de liberté
bien plus considérable
que celle de la plupart
des êtres humains aujourd'hui.
Faire objection de croissance,
c'est donc aussi tenter de s'évader
de cette cage d'acier
dont nous sommes prisonniers,
de sortir de cette roue infernale
dans laquelle nous tournons sans fin
comme des hamsters.
Ce ne sera certes pas facile.
L'une des choses qui nous
retiennent dans cette cage,
ce sont les marchandises
qui s'y accumulent,
merveilleuses et fascinantes marchandises.
Comment résister
à leur pouvoir d'attraction ?
Il est évidemment bien plus facile
d'aller à l'épicerie du coin
offerte à un prix dérisoire,
que de fabriquer soi-même cette pizza.
La cage d'acier a quelque chose
d'un pays de cocagne
où les poulets rôtis
vous tombent tout cuits dans le bec.
Mais c'est un piège, un terrible piège :
plus nous subvenons à nos besoins
à l'aide de marchandises,
plus celles-ci se rendent
indispensables,
moins nous devenons capables
de nous en passer,
plus les entreprises qui les produisent
deviennent alors nécessaires et puissantes,
plus se renforce, en définitive,
la course à la croissance
et ses règles du jeu contraignantes.
Bref, acheter une pizza surgelée
à 3 $ à l'épicerie du coin
coûte en réalité très cher,
puisqu'il en va de notre autonomie
et de notre liberté la plus essentielle.
Vous en doutez ?
Pensez à cette marchandise
particulièrement séduisante,
qu'est l'automobile.
Nous avons aujourd'hui la liberté
d'en acquérir une assez facilement,
nous avons le choix
entre de nombreux modèles
et de multiples marques.
En revanche,
il y a une liberté
dont nous ne disposons plus,
c'est celle de vivre sans voiture.
Même ceux qui comme moi
n'en ont pas,
dépendent étroitement
dans leur quotidien de l'automobile.
Si les voitures de la région montréalaise
ne peuvent plus rouler demain,
ce sera le chaos absolu
pour tout le monde,
même pour moi.
Comme dit le philosophe Louis Marion,
acheter une voiture,
ce n'est pas acheter seulement
un moyen de déplacement,
c'est acheter une civilisation.
Avec la bagnole,
vient toute une armada :
la route, le parking, les bétonneuses,
les diverses pollutions,
la défiguration du paysage
et les catastrophes industrielles,
comme celle de Lac-Mégantic,
sans compter les morts
et les accidentés de la route.
À ces contraintes lourdes
sur le plan collectif,
s'ajoute le temps passé individuellement
à gagner l'argent nécessaire
pour utiliser cette machine
et le temps perdu dans des embouteillages,
causés par ces mêmes machines.
Bref, vu sous cet angle,
la voiture n'a rien de cet instrument de liberté
que les publicitaires
continuent de nous faire miroiter.
Et ce qui vaut
pour cette marchandise emblématique
vaut pour toutes les autres.
Elles tendent, au bout du compte,
à réduire bien plus notre autonomie
que notre labeur.
Voilà pourquoi il est essentiel
de résister à leur charme ensorceleur.
Voilà aussi pourquoi
il faut rompre résolument
avec cette course
à la production de marchandises
dans laquelle nous sommes entraînés.
Au total et en résumé,
refuser la croissance économique s'impose
pour au moins 3 raisons essentielles :
parce qu'elle est destructrice
sur le plan écologique,
parce qu'elle n'améliore plus
le sort de la majeure partie d'entre nous
et enfin parce qu'elle est aliénante,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle nous empêche
d'exercer notre liberté
et de rester maîtres de nous-mêmes.
Il me semble que ce sont là
des raisons amplement suffisantes pour,
comme je le disais au départ,
cesser d'entretenir l'espoir
que notre civilisation
fondée sur la croissance
perdure encore longtemps.
Et plus vite
nous abandonnerons cet espoir,
plus nos chances d'éviter le pire
augmenteront.
Reste une série d'objections.
J'en évoquerai 3 rapidement :
la première,
la plus évidente,
une décroissance volontaire
à l'échelle planétaire
est-elle vraiment envisageable ?
N'est-ce pas un projet
totalement utopique ?
Il est grand temps, je crois,
de renverser l'accusation.
L'utopie aujourd'hui,
c'est de continuer à penser
qu'une croissance économique infinie
soit possible dans un monde fini.
Les rêveurs ou les affabulateurs
sont ceux qui entretiennent cet espoir.
Mais, deuxième objection :
la croissance n'est-elle pas
dans la nature de l'homme ?
Celui-ci ne cherche-t-il pas toujours
à améliorer sa condition
et n'entre-t-il pas alors nécessairement
en concurrence avec ses semblables,
puisque les ressources terrestres
sont limitées ?
Il suffit de faire un peu d'histoire,
d'anthropologie ou d'éthologie,
pour réaliser que l'homme n'est pas
forcément un loup pour l'homme,
qu'il n'est pas toujours
cet animal égoïste
cherchant à maximiser son utilité
que nous présente
la théorie économique standard.
Si beaucoup d'êtres humains
semblent agir aujourd'hui
conformément aux prédictions
de cette théorie,
c'est la conséquence de la course
à la croissance qui leur est imposée
et non pas sa cause.
Non seulement nous sommes capables
de coopérer entre humains,
mais nous en avons profondément besoin.
En ce sens,
nos sociétés qui nous placent
en situation de concurrence permanente
les uns contre les autres,
sont proprement inhumaines.
Et c'est pourquoi
il faut en réinventer les bases.
Troisième et dernière objection :
mais avez-vous un plan, un programme,
un modèle au moins ?
D'une part,
je ne crois pas qu'il soit possible
de planifier l'innovation radicale.
Il y a là une contradiction fondamentale
dans les termes.
D'autre part, il y a un grand danger
à vouloir mettre en œuvre
un plan prédéfini
qui vaudrait pour tout le monde
et en tout lieu.
Pour ne pas accoucher du pire,
l'invention de sociétés post-croissance
doit être rigoureusement démocratique.
Cela suppose d'abord qu'une majorité
d'entre nous soient convaincus
de la nécessité d'en finir avec
la course à la croissance.
Je suis venu cet après-midi
pour vous demander de contribuer
à former cette majorité. Merci.
(Applaudissements)